kylie jenner to the foyer
kylie jenner to the foyer i have a
little surprise for you
[Applause]
wait what is that yeah
remember that one time kylie jenner
accidentally mistook a pig for a chicken
on keeping up with the kardashians
well the beauty mogul's three-year-old
daughter stormy webster
just channeled that iconic moment and
it's the clucking
cutest thing you'll see all day i love
it on sunday kylie shared
these sweet snaps of stormy dressed in a
chicken costume
the caption is that a chicken of course
that caption is a reference to a 2016
episode of keeping up with the
kardashians
where kylie thought her mom kris jenner
had bought her a chicken as a gift for
her new house
[Applause]
wait what is that what is that
it's okay baby is that a little pig it's
wilbur
you don't have to name it wilbur i just
named it that's right
yeah so that whole chicken pig confusion
went viral
and kylie later took to snapchat to
explain herself
my mom asked me what i wanted for my
housewarming gift and i told her i want
chickens i want a chicken coop i'm like
dying to have a chicken we had like over
10 conversations about it so when i saw
her downstairs with something all
wrapped up in her arms and i was
upstairs
of course i assumed that it was a
chicken
i never asked for a pig but yeah i just
wanted to make the public announcement
um that i do know the difference between
a chicken and a pig
so you guys don't have to worry the
happy ending here
kylie eventually got a little chicken of
her own
of course this is hardly the first time
the famous family has taken to social
media to pay tribute to one of their
memorable moments on the show
you already have this well i can't wear
it because do you see the back it's the
thong
what do you think i am you know where
thong i mean not
not in public oh wow you are
conservative
in 2020 kourtney kardashian and her pal
addison ray posted
not one but two throwback keeping up
reenactments
i mean i feel fine i just cry myself to
sleep every night
yeah that's totally normal but back to
stormy
she's the cool one when the
three-year-old fashionista isn't busy
dressing up like her mom's favorite
animal
she is busy living her best life
enjoying
easter egg hunts go sami
taking walks with her cousin true
hitting the slopes
and who could forget stormy's
over-the-top third birthday bash in
[Applause]
february
happy birthday to
[Music]
you